-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much going on
right now.
Supreme Court justice Stephen
Breyer is stepping down.
Everyone's talking about
"Encanto."
A winter hurricane might be
headed for the East Coast.
And Pizza Hut just released
its spiciest pizza ever.
Let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, Justice Breyer.
He's retiring after nearly
30 years on the Supreme Court.
Democrats are already talking
about who should replace him.
But you know who
they're not talking about?
Bruno.
"Encanto" is huge right now.
It's got an amazing soundtrack
by Lin-Manuel Miranda,
and two of the songs
are currently
in the Billboard Top 10.
The music is rocking everyone
like a...
hurricane.
That's right. A bomb cyclone
with the power of a hurricane
is headed for the Northeast.
And if you want to experience
your own personal bomb cyclone,
why not try...
Pizza Hut's new
Spicy Lover's Pizza?
It's their spiciest pizza ever.
With red jalapeños
and chili peppers.
It will mess you up so bad,
you'll have to...
retire.
Whoever fills Breyer's seat
will be stuck in that role
for years to come.
Speaking of things
getting stuck for years,
the "Encanto" soundtrack.
We're gonna be singing
these songs for a long time.
It's basically the new...
"Frozen."
To prepare, people are stocking
up on water and toilet paper,
but not because of the storm,
because they just tried...
Pizza Hut's new
Spicy Lover's Pizza.
In conclusion, time to go...
let it snow...
get that dough...
♪ We don't talk about Bruno,
no, no, no ♪
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Well, as I mentioned,
this weekend,
a giant winter storm is heading
for the East Coast.
But I saw this one tweet
from NBC News
that wasn't super-helpful.
It said New York City could see
between 2 inches and 20 inches
of snow this weekend.
-[ Laughter ]
-Oh, thanks a lot.
-Yeah, now I know.
-Pretty big range right there.
I don't know --
Who's making these predictions?
The CDC?
[ Laughter ]
"Six feet, three feet,
ten days, five days.
We don't know. We don't know."
Yeah, so you'll either be
going to work
or you'll be buried
inside your house,
so get ready.
Some business news.
Bud Light just announced they're
releasing Bud Light Next,
a zero-carb beer that they spent
nearly ten years trying to make.
Ten years.
Wow. Somehow it took a few
months for the Pfizer vaccine,
but ten years
for Bud Light Next.
Here's some good news.
Delta Airlines
will soon bring back
hot meal service on its flights.
Meanwhile, Spirit is like,
"That's why we put the engine
in the cabin, so people can
heat up whatever they want."
Hey, guys, I read that Elon Musk
took his kids to Walmart
so they could see the pandemic
toilet-paper shortage
firsthand.
[ Laughter ]
His kids were like,
"This is crazy, Dad!
Why don't they just use
$100 bills like we do?"
"That's right.
Let's go home now."
Finally, I heard,
because of staff shortages,
the governor of New Mexico
had to fill in
as a substitute teacher
at an elementary school.
Yeah, it's pretty effective
when the teacher says,
"Behave, or I'm raising your
parents' property taxes."
We have a great show.